i i love ryan fitzpatrick
but
this isn't some
unique indignity that's been visited
upon him guys get benched all the time
and when he says he got fired dude
you're still getting paid yeah no you're
getting paid a lot of money you're right
that's not fired no right that's uh if
that's fired um sign me up dolphins i'll
come down right now brian flores call me
up i'm ready
you can fire me every day
i i i don't know how serious he is about
it when he says it like that it's just
so jarring because
that's not what you expect from him and
and how often do you have a guy who gets
benched at any position
who who publicly complains about it with
those kinds of terms again not fired
here's his salary for this year it's
eight million dollars that is for each
and every week that he sits on the bench
470 000 bucks yeah we should all be so
fired chris yes exactly you know i mean
first off hey i understand he's
disappointed we talked about it
yesterday he's been playing some pretty
good football you know there's been no
pressure on the team because there's no
expectations i'm sure he's loving it and
doing you know all the aspects of it and
probably feels like hey we're we're kind
of building something we're three and
three here we go we've played pretty
good you know so i think that probably
excited him his family i'm sure it's a
tough pill to swallow there's no doubt
about it but
he had to have known that
you know there at some point during this
year this was going to be a conversation
regardless of record that they were
going to try to infuse him in there at
some point and when i say him i mean tua
and yeah this kind of fights back
against the notion that you know ryan
fitzpatrick is the perfect guy for this
situation and he won't cause any
problems and i don't think he'll cause
any problems but yesterday yeah those
comments is like um they're sulking you
know he's he's be he's sulking and and a
bad day and i don't know if you air that
out to the media but yeah that's the way
it works in the nfl you know you lose
your job and you got to sit there in the
room with the guy that told you you're
losing your job and then you also got to
sit there in the room with a guy who
just took your job and they replaced you
with it that's life in the nfl so it's
no different for him or anybody other
other position or anything like that out
there quarterback becomes a little more
personable that way because we see their
faces and everything more like that but
uh hopefully he you know quiets it down
and starts supporting tua here from from
here on out
let's hear a little bit more from ryan
fitzpatrick on hearing the news that he
would be placed on the bench in favor of
tuatanga viloa
i was
shocked by it
you know it definitely caught me off
guard
and uh
you know it was it was a hard thing for
for me to hear uh yesterday just kind of
digesting the news
um
my heart just hurt all day this
organization and what we've been through
the last year and a half
you know it
this was kind of the first place other
than buffalo where
i was i just felt
fully
you know committed and invested
and
felt like it was my team
um
you know and so that to have that
um i think that's a lot of the reason
why
i just
my heart was so heavy yesterday but
um you know that that's the direction
that the organization's going and you
know i just gotta
accept it
two observations first of all why would
you let yourself think that it's your
team thank you when they just use the
fifth that's the number one on a quarter
i mean you're misleading yourself that's
your fault right that's the first thing
i thought of too when i saw that go
ahead sorry i didn't mean interrupt yeah
one here's the other point yeah it's not
like they're making every player
available to the media now that they do
these video press conferences and
typically it's an easy way to tuck a guy
into the corner on a day when maybe he
wouldn't be thrilled with what's going
on i don't know why they made him
available yesterday he's not the
starting quarterback and they're on a
bye week why in the hell did they make
him available i appreciate the
transparency but if i'm the pr director
of the miami dolphins ryan fitzpatrick's
not talking to the media on the
wednesday of our bye week he's not the
starter there's no obligation this week
to do anything
we're not making him available yeah
period yeah well maybe the maybe the
dolphins just want to get it out of the
way right that would probably be my
thinking like just get it out of the way
right now where he can talk to the media
and then and next week it's all tua and
we're not still talking about the
replacing of ryan fitzpatrick yeah maybe
i'm wrong i don't know i uh i think if
they knew i think if they knew what he
was going to say
yeah i i think they they misread the
room i i mean
i don't totally disagree with that
either mike you're right i don't think
they probably expected him to kind of
say some of the things he said here and
not that it's like
crossing the line with what he said but
he's certainly making it a little
uncomfortable and you know
you know right on the edge there of to
where coaches and people in the
organization are not gonna like it you
know you could see he's truly he's truly
beat up about this he looks like he's
you know he looks like pale like he's
you know a little bit like in shock or
this whole thing and i'm not trying to
be funny or anything it's it's hurt his
heart i believe that i do but i think
the big thing is what you just said i
mean i don't know why he let himself be
misled by himself
to think that this was his team
and that
basically anything other than 6-0
was probably the only thing that could
have saved his job at this point to
where he would have kept going but i
mean they were looking for their moment
to slide him in
bye week teams where it's at where where
it's in a good spot where it can support
tua and we know where the schedule is
and it makes a lot of sense and
hopefully he can understand that uh from
from their organizational standpoint
i think a lot of this may just be a
manifestation of the fact that he
is frustrated with himself for allowing
himself to think that and i'm surprised
he's so candid with it because this is
the guy who went to harvard if you
haven't heard how does he let himself
develop this blind spot this delusion
that he's got this job that this is his
team what did he think was going to
happen this year what did he think was
going to happen next year he's going to
hold tuatanka vialoa off for multiple
seasons he's going to be the brett favre
to two is aaron rodgers are you kidding
me and
pete pointed out that
on sunday when tour got in the game fitz
was his biggest fan and rilling up the
crowd he was chilling yeah he didn't
know what was coming oh yeah very easy
to be supportive of your backup when
your backup finally gets a chance to
play because you're up 24 nothing i
think part of that was the exuberance of
we just beat the 49ers 43 to 17. that's
right now we're shutting out the jets
i'm golden this is my gig
and if i guess if the dolphins did
anything wrong chris they they never
really bothered
to point out the obvious that
even if you're playing well and he had
two interceptions on sunday but still
they shut out the jets but even if
you're playing well and even if things
are going great
you're going to get the hook at some
point potentially when we think two is
ready period yeah i mean you just you
got to always be thinking that no matter
how you know well you're playing i never
really got into a situation totally like
a ryan fitzpatrick where is similar but
it's just got to be in the back of your
mind at some point that they're they're
going to try to do this now he was with
a guy i think and shan galey who's was
also the offensive coordinator in the
place where he said he you know felt
most comfortable in his career which was
buffalo so i'm sure between that and his
comfort in the offense and some of the
communications he's at with shan galey
and
the fact that i doubt this was a
shanghaily decision this is as you said
yesterday and you've said for a while
this is i mean this is the higher ups
these are the owners the gm the head
coach
and i think at the end of the day
probably it shocked him from that
standpoint too because there was
probably no warning sign at all you know
sometimes when things like that happen
your offensive coordinator your
quarterback coach kind of lets you know
those conversations are going on a
little bit you know like hey you might
you might have to play better this week
you know there there there was some talk
you know just to let you know so you
know those type of things go on and i
doubt that went on and that's probably
why it was so shocking as well
and here's what hasn't happened yet and
i don't know that it will and part of
the problem is that this year you don't
get reporters in the locker room like
you do in any other year when there
isn't a global pandemic
but we
we saw it earlier this week from the
cowboys players who aren't happy with
the coaching staff in dallas
have we seen anything from any unnamed
player
suggesting disagreement with the
decision to flip
no i'm ryan fitzpatrick
of iloa and you've got veterans there
who want to win now they don't want to
hang around and and and see what happens
next year there may not be a next year
for some of these guys now that may be a
testament to brian flores ability to
well that too clamp down yeah right it
may be a little of the bill belichick
approach where nobody's saying anything
and any of you that say something i will
find out and don't think i won't they're
not going to chance it even though it's
going to be hard for him to find out
right that may have something to do with
it too i wouldn't be shocked and you
know the other thing is they're drinking
the kool-aid down there i mean they they
should be
i mean
they've turned the organization around
i'm sure the guys there go wait
every button that chris greer and flores
have touched so far it's kind of worked
out and we've gone in the right
direction here so let's just trust them
you know that does go on in the locker
room as well
you know the the the big thing i'll keep
that that really sticks out to me where
i think is the biggest issue in this
whole situation
is the 49ers game you just brought it up
and to me that's where i wanted to start
the 49ers game if they had lost that
game nobody no matter what they beat the
jets and the jaguars nobody would be
saying anything about them benching ryan
fitzpatrick at two and four but they won
that game
unexpectedly 49ers were in a tough spot
and we know all that and then
fitzpatrick and the miami dolphins
played well no doubt but that's what i
think has thrown the
his own realm of perception out there a
little bit and probably where it shocked
us a little as well because of that game
it held him and the team in a little bit
of a higher standard and i'm sure that's
what made them panic once again because
they went in the bye week and they went
wait we're three and three yeah we could
lose to the rams and be three and four
but we can easily win the next four or
five games after that
and then what do we do we can't pull the
switch or pull the plug then and i think
that's where they ultimately probably
sat down on sunday night and realized
they were in a tough spot and how to
make this type of move another reason to
make the move during the bye week so you
can work out all of these various
emotions that's right configure the team
toward the new starting quarterback and
ryan fitzpatrick
despite his disappointment despite the
things he said that were far more candid
than anyone would have imagined he did
say that he will be assisting the new
starting quarterback as best he can
here's more from fitz on the positive
side of this development as it relates
to tua taking over
once this thing starts up again
um you know i've got to do my best
for tua to help him out because it's
there's two separate situations here one
is
with tua and i want him to do well and i
think he's a great kid and i think he
has a really bright future and the other
one is you know my
feelings and uh just kind of what i'm
going through and that has to be
separate from
when i walk into this building and you
know help him out i've got to separate
those feelings from
um
you know trying to be a professional and
help him out as best i can
and that's good and he needs to do that
i just yeah think that some of those
feelings probably didn't need to bubble
up for the benefit of all of us although
thank you we needed some content this
morning and ryan fitzpatrick gave it to
us so
uh
i i i i suspect that it will be fine by
the time we get to next week they're
going to have the rams to get ready for
they don't have time
to sit around and try to work this out i
don't think brian flores is going to
want to waste any of his time trying to
work this out he's going to trust that
ryan fitzpatrick understands you're
getting 470 grand a week deal with it
yeah whether we play or not you're
getting this money we didn't cut you and
you know should they should they
this came up yesterday when shireen
williams and i were discussing this
because
she thinks that the dolphins should do
right by ryan fitzpatrick and maybe
trade him
if that's what he wants i don't think
they should because they need him in the
event tua gets hurt right quarterback if
tua gets hurt i don't think they have
any obligation to him other than to pay
him a check every week no no i i don't i
don't either you know i i don't look at
it that way nor is this a situation to
where
you know it's one thing if the guy's
been there and carrying your franchise
and doing all these great things he's
been there for two years i don't think
it's that type of thing he understood
what he signed up for here
so i yeah i i don't i don't totally see
it that way
um
fitzpatrick will do the right thing we
know that i i have no doubt that he'll
be the right mentor and approach it all
the right way as he goes forward uh it's
a tough time it's what stinks about
football i mean football is brutal that
way you have your rip heart you know
your rip you know your heart ripped out
of you all the time um but i i do think
you almost gave us one you i almost did
you're right it almost slipped through
you have your you have your you have
your rip heart
rip hearted but but have your parted
that's why i do think going back to a
little earlier that's probably why they
did this yesterday yeah they didn't
expect to maybe have some of the quotes
that he let out but i think you know
what you just said the bye week all that
get it out of the way so now we focus on
the rams tua i'm sure they're going to
have a few days off here because of that
and he'll get to recharge and figure out
you know his approach going forward and
i think everything will be fine and
dandy there next week in miami
well if ryan fitzpatrick was surprised
by the news he wasn't alone here's tua
on his reaction to finding out that he's
the new starting quarterback in miami
you know you never know when when your
opportunity is given and
when coach flo called me i thought it
was
like any other call we usually watch
film on tuesdays
and so i thought he was calling because
he wanted me to come up and and
you know watch some film so i i usually
you know get with him um to watch film
but
it was different
i just think that you you need to be
ready every every time so
you know opportunities come and when
they come you just gotta you gotta take
them and run with them
we saw what tua can do with that back in
his freshman year at alabama he got the
opportunity in place of jalen hurts and
he ran with it all the way to a national
championship and that's when the legend
was born and that's what the dolphins
are hoping that he can do and we're
going to find out you know a point
someone made yesterday that i hadn't
thought of
the idea that the dolphins hold
the texans first-round pick we don't
know where the texans are going to land
in the pecking order but
you need to see what tua has because
you may be in position to do the arizona
cardinals josh rose in one year kyler
murray the next year you just got to see
what tua has as part of your broader
decision-making process on what to do
with that pick that you got from the
texans in the larry mutunsel kenny
stills trade yeah that that's amazing
well it just shows you again you know
miami and they should trust the these
guys that are running the organization
in greer and flores because
i mean wow the teams improved this much
they got all these assets again going
into
another offseason
and yeah quite possibly listen you know
as we've talked about a lot here trevor
lawrence is looking like it's going to
be the greatest fight ever for one
player it really is and right now pete
just got in my ear and said the texans
would be sitting there at the seventh
pick of the draft so hey they'll be able
to make moves if they want to but
i think they drafted tua thinking this
is our guy it's why they got shan galey
there it's an offense they believe fits
him and they're gonna try to now build
the rest of the team around them and i
i'd like to see it go that route i love
trevor lawrence he's awesome but hey
let's build a team and then as long as
you just got a good quarterback you
could still win and you can win a whole
lot of games for a long long time and
then maybe he'll become great as you put
that good team around him and uh i think
too many times we're looking for that
one guy too much here in in recent
history
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports